I hate intros psychopaths season 1 we
take things off with the 10th standoff
between the main character shinya kogami
going against the sinister antagonist
named shogo makishima but we're getting
way ahead of ourselves so let's jump
back a bit we get introduced to
inspector akane tsunemori who's rushing
on to a crime scene she meets up with no
butt cheek gugino's oh who she was
assigned to as a new member of the
Public Safety Bureau which in this world
are the guys who come after you when
she's underage they're going after a guy
who was flagged by street skater and
supposedly very dangerous we're then
introduced to the muscle of the group
cult enforcers which are criminals that
act as hunting dogs to find other
criminals we have the main bro from the
beginning shinya kogami shoots a kaga be
Yayoi kun azúcar and Tama mimasaka the
weapons they use are called dominators
which one pointed at a person determines
their psychopath levels it then judges
how much force is necessary to deal with
the threat using this simple system a
committee is assigned to go with kogami
and Misaka as they spread out to find
the suspect cog he finds him first as
he's trying to rape a girl so he has to
take action who suspects crime
coefficient is over 190 so the Dominator
is set to stun but he's on stimulant so
it doesn't work after that his score
ramps up so when kogami gets the drop on
him his Dominator uses lethal force and
the perv goes pump because the victim he
was trying to rape was under such harsh
conditions her score had skyrocketed
crossing the lethal force as well kogami
seizes and he decides that he's gonna
deal with her also akame begs him not to
but after being ignored she is forced to
shoot and paralyze kogami to protect the
girl
episode 2 strangely enough even after
that hectic situation I can a score or
hue didn't change that much indicating a
high fortitude and her score when she
gets back to work she meets with shield
Karim Inori who was an analyst at the
bureau and a latent criminal like the
enforcers
kogami is still in the hospital
recovering from the paralysis and
aki-nee regrets putting him there a new
threat is detected so moussaka and
alchemy are sent out to deal with it
they use their futuristic technology to
disguise themselves as robots and
quickly apprehend the threat when kogami
wakes up akane goes to apologize to him
but he doesn't hold anything against her
in fact he's grateful because he was
reminded that he wants to be a detective
not a mindless hunting dog he episode 3
the gang are sent out to investigate a
death caused by a drone they suspect it
was made to look like an accident but in
actuality it was a murder the facility
is completely disconnected from outside
networks to avoid hacking this means
that the dominators can't access the
civil system and won't work their
primary suspect becomes one of the
employees who was constantly bullied by
the others kogami interrogate the man
really aggressively and this triggers
him so he tries activating his drones to
kill kogami this score wasn't being
affected by him killing people which is
why they had to lure him out using this
tactic the other enforcers managed to
set up a portable Network bringing the
dominators online and they quickly
paralyzed the culprit while destroying
his killer drones as well
episode 4 everybody is investigating a
new incident that left a man missing and
after checking his apartment they find
Sunday he could have been murdered the
victims avatar in virtual reality is
very popular amongst the online
community known as talisman even though
he is missing his avatar is still being
piloted by somebody so they go to check
it out in virtual reality
well there hakuna is brought into a chat
room with spooky boogie she feels spooky
boogie and on a bit of what's going on
so spooky boogie schedules in IR all get
together which talisman will have to
attend or his popularity will plummet
well at the party Akane tries to get
close to use the Dominator to see his
score but a new character he's working
for named Cho tip suma Haven hack all of
the attendees holo cosplays and switched
them to the talisman avatar so that he
can escape in the crowd the woman behind
spooky buggy is then attacked and rely
for her cooperation with the bureau the
culprits then plan on becoming spooky
boogie just like they did with talisman
II episode 5 after studying spooky
boogie speech patterns kogami figured
out that somebody else was piloting the
character they follow this up and go to
her place in real life nearly getting
blown up by a bomb that was placed there
after thinking about it they figure out
that the murderer has to be a fan to
imitate their avatars perfectly they
attract users too that went offline
after the victims die and find his
identity masa Takumi Doe he gets caught
out at his apartment forcing him to flee
while taking a shot from kogami the
other agents find him at his second
place while having him meltdown and they
kill him we get a little back story on
kogami when occu Mei finds out that he
used to be an inspector but his score
fell apart after dealing with a case
leading to his demotion to enforcer
episode 6 we get some more details on
kogami and his last case as inspector
we're one of his friends working the
case sasayama wound up being a victim in
the end the specimen case was never
solved and kogami is still obsessed with
it and avenging his friend jump over to
some students were Rika ko one of the
more popular girls that the school
recruits another girl into her arc
we then go over to the interrogation of
the drone murderer who tells them that
he was sent the coats to turn the drones
into killers by a new mastermind kogami
suspects the same man that killed his
partner three years ago as he would
enable people to kill by giving them the
tools to do so the schoolgirls body is
later found displayed as an art piece
meanwhile in the art club Rica Cote
draws messed-up pictures while the man
who squared off with a kogami in Episode
one and the presumed mastermind sits
behind her a Episode seven the artistic
murder is too close to the specimen case
so Kagame is taken off of it back to the
students where the new art club her crew
is now missing and her friends were
talking about it one of her friends had
heard that Rica ko was seen with her so
she goes to ask if she knows anything
this leads to her being turned into a
messed up art display along with her now
dead friend yep so date Kagame gets a
hunch that the killer could have
something to do with Rococo because of
the connection between the way the
bodies were displayed and her dead
father's artwork wouldn't they go to
question her she bolts and manages to
get away because of a teacher
interfering they have security pictures
of her going into the garbage disposal
facility and once inside they find the
next art piece with the two missing
girls well going over the other security
footage a lot of it was tampered with
but they managed to recover sound from
one clip with makishima's name on it in
the last scene makishima betrays Ricky
Coe and has a mysterious hunter with
robot dogs blow her head off
episode 9 the creepy hunter is revealed
as tolya he says Sangji and is entirely
cyborg except for his brain Kagame and
occu may go to kogami's former teacher
Joshi psycho who aids in the
investigation makishima talks with
senggigi about having him kill kogami
meanwhile he knows it gets pissed that
aki-nee went with kogami to see Shoji
and they end up getting into a fight
over it who's worried about aki-nee
score rising too much and having her
career ruin which is what happened to
his father and Kagame II episode 10 ah
you may ask Kagame to go with her to try
and find her friend that went missing
named yuki cuca he goes into an
abandoned subway line where he finds
yuki but they end up getting isolated
from the others they are brought to
Sangha she's hunting
where he tries to kill them while
makishima watches as a third party after
a couple of near-death instances kogami
manages to get ahold of the others and
relay their position a episode 11 when
the others arrive at the hunting grab
they send a drone in that manages to
find kogami and deliver him a Dominator
which allows him to fight back
nuki is able to lure sankiji
into a trap giving Kagame the opening to
land the killing blow although the
threat is down Kagame is still injured
which allows makishima to step in and
take yuuki a kanay arrived shortly after
and finds Kagame to then rush ahead to
stop makishima she finds them both on a
catwalk in makishima decides that he
wants to test a kanay her Dominator
won't release the safety because for
some reason his score isn't high at all
and in fact is even dropping he drops
his shotgun down to her and says that if
she wants to kill him she has to do it
without the Sibyl systems help the
pressure gets to her when she tries to
use the shotgun and she ends up wasting
both of the shots makishima is
disappointed that she fainted kill him
so as punishment he slits Yuki's throat
killing her the episode well we get a
flashback three years ago of the less
talked about enforcer Yayoi she is a
former musician that was
institutionalized as a latent criminal
Gugu me brings her on to an
investigation to help with a case
because she knew the area well on the
case we get some your reaction when she
runs into her old crush Brina Brina
turns out to actually be a part of the
group of criminals that they're trying
to stop and she tries to recruit Yayoi
Yayoi refuses and tries to use a
Dominator but she isn't authorized
because she's not an enforcer allowing
greenie to get away this leads to Yayoi
asking Kagame if she could become an
enforcer he episode 13 back to the
present he knows that meets with the
head of the bureau Jo shook a say
concerning makishima she ends up
revealing the identity of the one
actually responsible for the specimen
case Tomoko Saburo who's criminally
asymptomatic and the bureau made him
disappear being asymptomatic means that
the Sibyl system can't measure him just
like makishima in order to prevent doubt
in the Sibyl system he is ordered to
bring back makishima alive meanwhile Aki
nee volunteers for a memory
scoop which is a dangerous procedure but
they managed to get an image of
makishima from what she saw we also find
out that massacre is actually gay noses
father that was demoted from inspector
to enforce her like kogami episode 14 a
new criminal in a fancy helmet kills two
people at a pharmacy while trying to
obtain drugs his score never went to
high and they assumed that it's because
of the helmet there's a second incident
of a man with the same helmet beating a
woman to death in the middle of a busy
street that gets posted online after
some digging they find out that the
helmet mimics nearby people scores to
throw off the civil system they track
down the man responsible for the beating
but he slips by them because his helmet
picks up on a kinase core she stays
behind so that they can use their
dominators and they quickly apprehended
the episode 15 hundreds of cases start
popping up of helmet users committing
crimes sending the entire city into
chaos the public aimed to take revenge
on the helmet users while the bureau
struggles to maintain any order Kouga me
figures that makishima is the one behind
this and this is just a piece of his
plan he realizes that the rides are
actually a distraction to pull police
away from Nona tower where the civil
systems core is located episode sixteen
makishima and his partner in crime Cho
get to the tower where they split up so
makishima can lure kogami away while
chill goes to destroy the civil system's
core Kagame kaga D and Akane arrived
shortly after and split up as well with
kogami go into the top floor with a
kanay and kaga d heading to the basement
kogami fights with some henchmen and at
long last we made it back to the opening
of episode 1 where kogami comes face to
face with makishima they get into a
pretty sick fight and just before kogami
gets stabbed
takanae jumps in to knock makishima
unconscious with her helmet she
contemplates killing him to avenge her
friend but can't bring herself to do it
and places him under arrest instead over
Ducati who caught up to Cho as they both
bind the core of the Sibyl system the
head of the bureau casei sneaks up
behind them and reveals that she is
actually a cyborg that overrides her
Dominator to kill both Joe and kaga D
she had to kill them to prevent them
from talking about what they saw in the
core II episode 17 the next day in the
aftermath the city is in shambles and
Kai Gotti is labeled missing casei tells
ki Nosa that makishima is going to be
taken off their hands without them
interrogating or prosecuting him which
pisses pretty much everybody off
makishima is then visited by casei who
reveals herself as cosa burro the
murderer in the specimen case who was
sharing a cybernetic body with casei and
the civil system the civil system is
actually a super computer network that
is made up of human brains that are
criminally asymptomatic like makishima
she tries to convince makishima to
become a part of the civil system but he
declines respectfully while attacking
her body and destroying it who then goes
on to escape from his transport and goes
missing
episode 18 Juno's has tasked with
finding makishima again while still
prioritizing his safety over everything
else casei orders that kogami not go
into the field because he might kill
makishima do you know who doesn't agree
with this call so he tries to find a
loophole to get kogami into the field
without getting caught gasps a picks up
on this plant and stops it out before
Kagame could escape she then tries to
convince quino's to kill Kagame by a
kanay steps in to paralyze him instead
saving his life when he wakes up he
convinces shown to lend him one of the
helmets Melissa could give some keys to
his safe house and he goes out on his
own leaving a letter for a kanay saying
that he's going after makishima ii
episode 19 kogami stays with saga while
he's laying low and trying to find out
where makishima might be the two of them
do some digging and comes to the
conclusion that makishima's next target
is Japan's food supply in the form of an
unmanned hyper oats facility over to AA
QA who was contacted by the Sibyl system
which tells her that they're going to
explain the truth a episode 20 the Sibyl
system leads Aachen aid to its core
where she learns that it's made up of
human minds they then asked for her
cooperation in detaining makishima alive
meanwhile makishima finds a professor
responsible for the hyper oats and
learns everything he needs to know in
order to get into the facility before
killing it back over to akame who agrees
to help the Sibyl system
in return she asked that kogami be left
unharmed kogami finds the dead professor
and leaves are recording at the murder
scene to let the others know that the
target is the high furrows granary
episode 21 Kagame arrives at the
facility first with the other showing up
soon after akame has the civil system
Locker dominator to the non-lethal
paralysis mode so she doesn't kill
Kagame
then shut off the power to the facility
and akane along with Yayoi go to the
control room to prevent makishima from
accessing the emergency power he knows a
massacre trip a wire causing an
explosion we think he knows a pin under
debris makishima comes out in fights
with moussaka and Misaka gets the upper
hand so makishima throws a bomb towards
his son this forces moussaka to decide
between saving Ginoza or apprehending
makishima of course massacre goes to
save his son but as he tries to throw
the bomb away it blows up dealing fatal
damage to him and he dies shortly after
Kagame arrives just in time to see this
egg goes after makishima episode 22
kogami catches up to makishima and they
have a little skirmish where kogami gets
the upper hand with makishima being
disarmed he brushes him with a knife but
before he can land the killing blow
Aachen 8 throws a paralysis grenade
between the both of them allowing
makishima to escape Julian convinces
kogami to help her go after him but
takes his revolver away and gives him
her Dominator that's set to stun
makishima attempts to escape in a truck
but akane jumps on the back of it
leaving kogami behind she manages to
shoot out the front tire causing the
truck to crash makishima tries to flee
on foot and akame is too injured to go
after him Kagame reaches her and
retrieves his revolver before chasing
after makishima he isn't going anywhere
fast because of the crash along with the
stab wounds he sustained so Kagame
catches up to him shortly after Kagame
then goes on to execute him finally
putting an end to his reign of terror we
jump ahead a bit and learned that the
Sibyl system determined that a kanay can
still be of use so they keep her alive
despite her failure after the death of
his father he knows the score had arisen
too much so he gets demoted to enforcer
Kagame is now missing and on the run to
avoid the consequences of killing
makishima I'm gonna be doing the future
seasons and that'll be in the bottom up
whenever I finish with it or you can
check out all the Psychopaths recap
in this playlist here you can also find
the links in the description below and
the only thing I hate more than intros
is outros